snack specifically scavenges the  peroxides released by white blood cells  which can then cause edema and for their  lung injury there was a portion of  coveted patients uh well a portion of  let me set this up they require a  ventilator that's a really bad thing  some people argue it's a death sentence  there's some doctors who say ventilator  is a bad idea there are some doctors who  say uh it's a good thing to use in these  hospitals a lot of doctors think that  we're going to them too early I'm not a  doctor but there are differing opinions  in the medical community Knack was found  to be useful as a prophylaxis agent  against forms of pneumonia and it  reduced the incidence of ventilator  Associated pneumonia by about 20 percent  so down from 46 percent to 26 percent  that's why the FDA is saying it's a drug  because it's clinically effective enough  to reduce being put on a ventilator and  it's safe and it's cheap and it's  available bam